die große suche und die große frage ist
natürlich was ist mit den juwelen
passiert was ist mit diesen kunstschatz
wird man ihnen noch einmal finden und
dabei möchte ich jetzt mit dem bild
reporter und kunstexperten dr jürgen
helfricht sprechen
sag uns welche bedeutung hat dieser
schatz der entwendet worden ist
überhaupt erst mal vor allem für sachsen
also für sachsen ist das ein stück der
sächsischen dna es ist eine art
staatsschatz schon seit mehr als 250
jahren die sächsischen könig und
kurfürsten hatten ihn zusammengetragen
mehrfach um gearbeitet dieser schatz
gruppe verwendet in notzeiten um einfach
nur ein beispiel zu bringen er besteht
ja aus mehreren hundert juwelen also die
jetzt gestohlen worden
um nur einer dieser diamanten hat man zb
für einen diesen diamanten hat augusta
starke im jahre 1700 28 2 tonnen gold
bezahlt und dafür habe er hunderte die
verschwunden sind also das ist ein
gewaltiger wert den auch rund 200.000
touristen jedes jahr besuchen und
bestaunen welche sorge hat man jetzt
rund um den schatz wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man all diese
branchen und anderen schmuckstücke
überhaupt wieder bekommt entweder im
ganzen oder zerlegt also bis zur
jetzigen sekunde ist nur bekannt dass
die täter gefasst wurden aber nicht die
entwendeten schmuckstücke wieder ist man
nicht habhaft geworden und das ist
natürlich eine große sorge dass dieser
schatz eventuell verteilt wird im
gegensatz zur goldmünze die man ja
eingeschmolzen hat die wirklich
wahrscheinlich unwiederbringlich
verloren ist aus berlin das im bode
museum könnte man hier denken dass diese
juwelen als diese diamanten vielleicht
um geschliffen werden das wird aber dazu
beitragen dass sie endgültig verloren
sind denn bei dem um schleifen gehen
etwa 30 bis 50 prozent des materials
verloren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren